welcome back to the time series tutorial
we are on part 1 fundamentals and we're
talking about subpar 10.3 linear
forecasting so one of the favorite jokes
prediction is difficult especially over
the future by Niels Bohr so the problem
is the one who mentioned the beginning
given a time series let's say
temperatures over the past 10 days
forecast what will happen in the 11th
day and the summary the summary recipe
is that we could use for linear
forecasting we could use the auto
regressive methodology also known as Box
Jenkins methodology which is part of the
ARIMA auto regressive integrated moving
average methodology this is related to
holt winters and also to Kalman filter
special cases so let's see the first
part of the regression and least-squares
remember the problem is forecast 11 day
and statistics textbooks textbooks say
that the first thing to do is to remove
trends if the temperatures go up we
should remove the trend and the second
step is to spot and remove periodicities
seasonally adjusted as the
meteorologists say then the brilliant
idea behind the boxing methodology is to
try to express the temperature of
tomorrow as a linear combination of
temperatures of the past the user has to
choose a width of W let's say W seven
days and then the author grass
methodology will find seven coefficients
a 1 a 2 a 7 so that the weighted sum
predicts the future as best as possible
let's go back to standard regression
before we go to auto regression this is
statistics introduction to statistics
suppose we have two variables patients
with two variables body weight and body
height for all the patients we know the
body weight for all except the last we
know the body height and the question is
how can we guess the body height of the
last patient
idea is to assume linear correlation
between body hybrid weight using
statistical terminology the what we know
is the independent variable in blue what
we want to guess is the dependent
variable
in red and linear regression says we
should fit a line on those points every
point is a patient with body hi body
weight and then one will want to guess
how much how tall should patient the
last patient be when we bring a line a
vertical line from the weight 25 units
of weight and then we bring a horizontal
line until we hit the vertical axis so
this up up and left motion we'll see it
again and again this is standard form
for forecasting for guessing the value
for regression okay this is standard
this is we all learned about it what
happens if for the time series suppose
we have temperatures as a function of
time or number of packets in a linear
computer network as a function of time
we want to figure out we know everything
up to now and we want to guess what will
happen the next time tick so clearly
this is the dependent variable that we
want to guess what is the independent
variable or variance and here is the
genius of box and Jenkins they say use
the same time series like by 1 so this
is the methodology with lag 1 and just
the window is only one just for
illustration but as we'll see later you
can work with any window so now the idea
is very clear we have a time series
which is delayed by 1 everybody except
for the first pair is not stuck nicely
except for the first and the last pair
so we're back to the original problem
every time T corresponds to a pair of
successive time ticks the horizontal
axis is the value before the vertical
axis the value after again we fit a line
and then we do the up up and left trick
so we guess that if we had 25 packets
the time think before we should have 555
Puckett's in the next time tick so the
dependent variable is the number of
packets enter time T and the independent
variable is the number of packets and
the time t minus 1 excellent this is
this works very nicely there are a lot
of details this is just the tip of the
iceberg right and among the most
interesting details are how to handle
windows of higher size more than one and
how to do it incrementally so let's see
the first part so how could we make it
work when we want to have a window of
two one we suspect that the temperature
tomorrow depends on the temperature
today and the temperature the day before
this is geometrically it is very easy
but now we have instead of points in
two-dimensional space we'll have points
in three-dimensional space we fit a
plane for the days temperatures tomorrow
today and yesterday and then if we want
to guess what will happen tomorrow we do
this the same trick move upwards and
then left and this is a guess how can we
do it mathematically
in addition geometrically they notice
that this is deep dive this is details
that we don't need to fully understand
the idea is that the problem becomes
another constraint problem with a lot of
equations as many as historical data we
have and very few knowns just the the
weights of the window we want if we want
the window of seven and we have seven
unknowns if we want the window one it's
just one unknown so the problem is
heavily over constrained but we know how
to solve it it's a very well understood
problem let me go
continue the deep dive and show how we
could turn the forecasting problem in
the matrix algebra problem right
so suppose we decide on a window of over
1 2 3 4 5 right so we have the first 5
days and their temperatures they form
the first equation the value want to
guess is the green value let's call it
y1 it's the temperature of the next day
the sixth day and this our first
equation
we slide the window by 1 the next 5 days
and the next day the day after that for
the next equation and so on and so forth
so we have as many equations as time
ticks minus five and as many unknowns as
the window we want five in this example
how do we solve it this is a closed
formula this this portion the pink
portion is the more penrose
pseudoinverse of the X matrix we showed
before the bottom line is that this is
an extremely well understood problem we
give it for homework in classes and this
is the solution there are many more
details can we estimate the seven
parameters who want are the five
parameters of the vector a incrementally
and it turns out that we can there is
the real method of least square so the
paper by he and the rest of us describes
exactly this method from textbooks and
the idea the high-level idea is that if
we have window one one dependent
variable and one independent variable
then we can fit a line to our historical
data the blue line if a new point comes
in then we don't need to repeat to solve
the huge big more penrose pseudoinverse
problem from scratch we can just update
some small equation set W by W matrix in
our case this will be one by one scalar
with a new point and we can compute the
new slope very quickly so this is the
recursively squares and strongly
recommended if you're working on
streaming data how can we handle
coevolving multiple more than one time
series remember one of the problems
mentioned in the beginning is what if
you have the three time series number of
packets and number of packets lost
number of packets repeated what will
happen in the eleventh day let's say for
the green packets for the repeated
packets the problem is mathematically
identical to regression actually it is
called vector Eamonn but the problem is
exactly the same we want to guess how
many repeated packets will have a time T
been
based on a window pick pick a window
size W let's sell calls five based on a
window five four the packets and packets
lost and packets repeated them the
numerical the mathematics are exactly
the same as before more per and also the
inverse and we can solve the problem so
the conclusion is that linear regression
is very well understood and the auto
regression with window one one two and
three is usually gives good results and
this methodology is the basis for more
complicated and even more successful
methods like Holt winters at Kalman that
we won't mention but will give pointers
here the citations the book the classic
book by George and Jenkins in its third
edition Brockwell is an even even more
advanced book the four Kalman filters we
had a tutorial in 2010 you're welcome to
take a look at the files are still on
the web and we are ready for part one
point for how to do nonlinear
forecasting
so first we'll see the problem then the
main idea then details experiments and
volterra log equations and conclusions
so the problem again is given a time
series figure out what will happen next
but the the footnote is that this is a
three time sequence this is chaotic or
or coming from a nonlinear different
differential differential equation in
that case linear method will not work
but the method that gives good results
is the so called delayed coordinate
embedding method which uses like plots
and then similarity search which is the
reason we spend so much time on
similarity search in the beginning so
here is a time series notice that they
are not really periodicities it seems to
be periodic but not really there is no
there seem to be spikes but the spikes
disappear here the spikes disappear
again after six periods there is one
disappearance so it's a very strange
time series and actually this time
series came from this difference
equation which is called the logistics
parabola
which was proposed by Sir Robert May one
of the main figures in population
ecology who proposed this model to model
the population of flies & insects
so instead of flies we have their Lady
Bird which is much prettier than the fly
so this equation makes a lot of sense it
says that the population of flies in the
next time take in the next year depends
on the population of flies this year
times that the reproductive rate how
many eggs flies tend to lay but there is
a throttling factor right if there are
too many flies then the reproductive
ability goes down because there is not
enough food to share there's not enough
oxygen in the laboratory professor me
and so on and so forth technically X is
not the count is the ratio the fraction
of the number of flies versus the
carrying capacity that the absolute
maximum number of flies we could fit in
a room right but the question makes
sense things propagate with a
reproductive rate unless this
reproductive rate starts get slowing
down because of the huge of the
population approaching huge capacity
this is the equation that we use to
generate the synthetic sequence and if
we plot XT as a function of X T plus 1
as a function of T will clearly get a
parabola which crosses with zero
crossings at 0 and at 1 right zero and
one ok this makes a lot of sense this
models real populations reasonably well
actually it's a very very successful
equation it also models a virus
propagation epidemiology for the
specific type of SSI susceptible
infected this virus that never goes away
people never get healed never never heal
and never recover so it's a virus from
hell
but this is also exactly this is also
very very similar to the bus equation
for market penetration so if there is a
product let's say this this marker right
if I tell you that hey this is a nice
marker and
ayee a fraction of you going by this
this marker this is exactly how the the
marker will penetrate the market
according to a very similar equation the
logistics parabola and also all we'll
see later this logistic parabola is a
special case of the so called
lotka-volterra equations which model not
only one type of species but multiple
type of species which are cooperating or
prey-predator relationship or some other
relationships so it's a very interesting
and very useful equation so how would we
forecast in the previous section we say
ok if we have a time series let's use it
or regression let's see why our
regression is not a good tool here
because let's say if we about the
regression of window one then this will
be what will what we are doing is we're
trying to fit an equation of this form
no matter what the intercept and the
slope this will never match the parabola
we're trying to fit a square peg in s in
a circle in a circle hole right so it
will never fit what should we do if we
know exactly the shape of the parabola
then then what we can do is we can do
the up up and left motion what is the
population of lies is here go up hit the
parabola go left this our guess for next
year if we don't know the parabola the
exact details of the parabola but we
have a lot of historic data how could we
go about it and that was the idea behind
things hours method says let's assume
that we have a window one is in half so
lag 1 and let's assume that four nearest
neighbors are enough so we have a lot of
historical data which are these stars we
don't know and actually we don't even
care if they're on a parabola or hyper
bar or anything else right but what we
do is we figure out what is the value
for today the population of lives for
today for this year then we look for the
four nearest neighbors on this
horizontal axis from those four nearest
neighbors
we do the up and left motion we'll go up
and see what happened after in those
four cases we figure out all these
points and then we interpolate among the
four the four forecasts something like
that so we get the Green Point so this
is the high-level idea behind the
delayed coordinate embedding method
there are a few details to discuss how
would we interpolate between the four
nearest neighbors and one obvious answer
is the average a second answer is the
weighted average weighted according to
how far away you are from the red point
the winning answer which actually gives
our used and the won first place in the
time series forecasting competition in
94 93 was to get the four nearest
neighbors figure out the points in their
appropriate dimensional space fit the
hyperplane using singular value
decomposition and then do the upward and
left motion so there are a few details
what is the right value of K to use for
nearest neighbors and how much should be
the lag in this example we had the log
of 1 XT plus 1 verse 60 and number of
neighbors was 4 what is the recommended
number of neighbors there are no hard
rules that things are said that the
number of neighbors should be some more
than one and less than but not too huge
because otherwise we average over the
whole population and in his experiments
a log of 16 gave good results there are
a lot of papers on how to choose the
appropriate log using using mutual
information and other complicated
techniques we weren't going to detail
so how does this work at all it seems to
make sense but is there a theory behind
it and now we're doing deep dive right
the answer is there is a theory and
actually there is a so-called Aikens
theorem which says that if you have a
long enough history of whatever quantity
you want to measure then you can do good
forecasting even if there are other
unobserved variables so let me give you
an example so suppose we want to
forecast the population of links that we
have been going after all along and
suppose that the links interact with
snow here because that's a predator
relationship right so and if and usually
and we can assume that they interact
with lotka-volterra equations which make
a lot of sense and which will show in
more detail later so what this says is
that here that the increment in the hare
population depends on the here now and
the reproductive rate how many rabbits
are being generated by a pair of rabbits
but this is reduced by how many rabbits
encounter a predator Lynx and the
probability that the rabbit will not
escape will not evade the predator right
similarly the Predators they will get a
lot of calories every time a predator
finds rabbit and eats it then it gets
calories and then it has it has the
capability to generate offspring if
there is no hair at all if there are no
rabbits at all then the Lynx will the
Predators will decrease in this model
with exponential decay right so if we
know both the number of predators and
the number of a preys we can figure out
exactly what will happen next
what if we only know the number of
predators it turns out that we don't
need to know the number of praise if we
have a long enough history of the
Predators this is the idea behind
takin's theorem and actually notice how
this this is called the state space so
this is a number of rabbits and this is
the number of links notice that if there
are a lot of rabbits the population of
links will go up which will make the
population of rabbits to go down because
they are divided by the links which will
make the population of links go down
because there's not enough food which
will give up opportunity to rabbits to
start multiplying because there are no
predators and the cycle will repeat this
is called the limit cycling dynamical
systems so this is according to this
model and this is from Wikipedia
according to this model we saw before
the population of predators will have
spikes as we saw for the real data the
population of prey will also have spikes
the green shape right and this will be
the limit cycle okay it's a triangle but
technically it's a limit cycle anti
keeps theorem says that if there is a
limit cycle between preys and predators
we will also have a limit cycle between
predators at time T and Predators at
time t minus 1 therefore whatever we are
whatever forecast we do with full
information of Lynx and rabbits we can
also do with enough information about
Lynx alone this is idea behind package
theorem the bottom line is that the
delayed coordinate embedding method has
the red calendar pinnings and this is
the reason it is successful so Voltaire
a lot a lot couple terror questions
we'll see them again later because they
help with gray box modelling
let's see how well this method works on
synthetic and real data experiments so
we tried it first on synthetic data data
generated by exactly this equation the
logistics parabola and it turns out that
if we do delayed coordinate embedding
auto regression will fail but with
delayed coordinate embedding we get this
is what we knew the red stuff this is
what we forecasted the green stuff and
if we superimpose the green we
forecasted with actual we see that it
matches very well at least for the first
few time things after a while as we
see very quickly nobody can do good
forecasting the second dataset is the
famous data famous equation by Lorenz
synthetic data set which try to model
the the weather so X is wind velocity y
is pressure Z is a humidity or something
like that so the differential equations
that model convection model the weather
look like that so this is the value of x
if i remember correctly as a function of
time for some choice of parameter for a
carefully chosen set of parameters a B
and C notice that it's not really
periodic there is a period but it keeps
on growing and then things go crazy and
then it's sort of looked periodic again
but then drops back into the previous
type of periodicity so this is this is
tricky and actually what happens there
is a very nice history here people in
the fifties famous mathematician the
fifties they said ok here are the
equations of the weather so we can
forecast the weather so let's talk about
how to control the weather and Lawrence
threw a bombshell saying that even if
you know the equations you cannot really
forecast the weather because you cannot
really forecast any nonlinear system
because of the butterfly effect if your
system has a limit cycle then everything
is good if you're here then you'll go on
the red triangle if you're a little bit
off you will go on the blue triangle
cycle right but if you have a strange
attractor as it happens in this case a
small deviation if you start from here
as opposed to here after a few time
steps you will be in a completely
different trajectory and this is the
so-called butterfly effect which says
postulates that if there is a butterfly
butterfly in China flapping its wings it
may have it will affect how hurricane in
Texas
a year later it goes goes through the
country
so the shocking discovery is that for
nonlinear systems there is a possibility
that even if we know even if you know
the differential equations that govern
the system we cannot do long term
forecasting the butterfly effect right
so with synthetic data generated by the
previous equations we try to do the
delayed coordinate embedding method and
yes it does good forecasting up to
several time ticks and then of course
the butterfly effect kicks in and nobody
can do good forecasting hey so let's go
back let's open a parenthesis this is
what we said so far is blackbox modeling
we we don't know anything we collect
historical data and we try to do
forecasting what happens if we believe
that the lotka-volterra equations is
true how can we use it to do better
forecasting so this equations model prey
predator relationships as we mentioned
before Lynx and rabbits they also can
model competing animals like rabbits and
goats they this is not a prey predator
relationship but they compete for grass
for example in resources the same is
competing products market penetration
people stocks versus bonds they all both
try to feed on the available income of
citizens and there is a competition if
we have only one species then this is
the best model how quickly a product we
penetrate the market and similarly if we
have only one type of virus how quickly
a virus will recover a population and so
on and so forth so these are extremely
useful equations for many settings the
gray box modelling the high-level idea
is as follows if we believe these
equations and if we have historical data
for AIDS for the hair the links then
what we can do is look at the historical
data we can try to estimate the these
parameters the reproductive parameter
for rabbits the reproductive the rate of
death the decay for a predator
slacking food and so on and so forth and
which was exactly the idea behind the
paper with Professor Yasuko matsubara
any associates are crying where the code
is in this website and the paper
appeared the few years are going after
them so the the goal was to guess how
competing products will evolve so these
are for game gaming gaming consoles Xbox
Playstation and so on the vertical axis
is the number of Google queries
normalized one and we see that the Xbox
Xbox starts high and then fluctuates and
so on the spikes as you can imagine are
during Christmas and to my surprise
there are also little spikes in May and
more little spikes in September which is
surprising given that school starts so
the goal is if these if we believe that
there are Voltaire a lot equations
during among these competing products
can we guess how they will evolve in the
future so the situation that we
conjecture that this paper conjectures
is that all these consoles they they
need resources the resources are the
available income the disposable income
from children teens and adults right and
this is exactly the same mathematical is
exactly the same situation as species in
an ecosystem fighting for resources so
squirrel monkeys they they need fruits
at a high degree and they can also
survive nuts but not their first
preference
Macau's they survive explicitly or nots
and we want to figure out how the
population of these species will evolve
so that's exactly the the problem
formulation and let's did I believe be
deeper on the lotka-volterra equations
which say that the population of species
I suppose we have these species in our
example head therefore consults game
consoles right suppose we have these
species so the population of Lynx
for next year will depend on the
population on links for this year and
also the reproductive rate of links how
many baby links are generated in a
couple throught it down by the
influenced by how much harm other
species do so a IJ is the harm factor of
species J rabbits to species I links in
this setting the the harm factor is
actually negative by the more the more
rabbits there are the happier the links
right but other things might be positive
if there are humans for example humans
don't species humans will have harmful
effect on on the links links themselves
the factor a I sub I are actually
harming each other because the more
links are available the less resources
are forgiven for a given specific links
and actually this this formulation can
model all all types of
interrelationships between species so if
both AI J and AJ I are both negative
this is symbiosis right this is the two
species that one helps the other like
short fish and pilot fish if they're
both positive this means that they're
competing if one is positive there is
negative it means that it's a prey
predator relationship if both are zero
this means that the species don't care
about each other it's like polar bears
and alligators right there there is
nothing they don't have anything in
common
the ki is the carrying capacity what is
the maximum number of Link's we could
possibly fit in this ecosystem if we
pack it with links from from coast to
coast so these equations are the
Volterra local lotka-volterra equations
and these are the ones that
professionals borrow tried to fit on
these time series after the fitting and
that using seasonality she was able to
train to compute the parameters fit the
parameters for the 2/3 of the experiment
and then forecast the last third and the
defeating was made a lot of sense was
close to reality
and as we said that the open source code
is here in Python if I remember
correctly
so this closes the parenthesis on grey
box modeling and the conclusions are
that if we have a chaotic nonlinear
systems and we are sure that auto
regression will not lead anywhere then
we can use lock plots and similarity
sets the name of the method of delayed
coordinate embedding this the paper by
teams our the one that won the
competition actually tied in first place
with a neural network of the 90s which
was not a deep network of course they
didn't exist yet but it was in a neural
network with linear with one hidden
layer and sigmoid functions if I
remember correctly the paperweight
Atkins the collection paper by Wiegand
and Gaston Feld and we are ready to
cover a point one point five their
tensors so tensions will help us model
time evolving graphs so if we have a
graph about what this this can be
modeled as a matrix as a graph what
happens if we have time evolving graphs
for example not only you know who both
what but you also have the time stamp
and notice that this person the
gentleman with a blonde here bought this
product two types 10:00 p.m. and 11:00
p.m. right so when we have such a time
evolving graph what are the models and
what are the tools we should use and the
answer is in that case tensors is a
powerful well understood dude let's see
some examples a tensor is actually a
generalization of a matrix so suppose we
have the rows are offers that published
in a dub dub dub 17 and the columns of
this matrix are keywords and entries how
many times author John used the term
data in his papers right how many times
author Mary used the data the term data
anchor papers and so on and that was dub
dub dub 17 dr. dub a till we do the same
thing in 0 pod if somebody didn't
publish or didn't use the word data we
fill the word
filled it with a blank with a zero and
the same for 19 so now instead of having
a matrix we have a stack of mattresses
and this is exactly called the tensor
the the
the axis of that tensor are called modes
or aspect so in this toy example the
first mode is the terms the second mode
is the humans they're authors and the
third mode is a time and then this can
help us do forecasting because if we try
to do straightforward forecasting
suppose as we'll see later we have a
real data set of who consume and when so
in this case if we want to do
forecasting we have four million people
calling for other million people if we
try to do forecasting on a on a pair
basis a collar collie basis then we
could need the four million square or
aggressive models so this would be
prohibitive plus it would be extremely
wasteful most of these pairs don't call
each other at all 0 0 0 la la right so
forecasting on a specifically on an
individual level is is a bad idea it
won't work it won't scale pencils will
help us solve this problem so the tool
that we will use is the so called
perfect parallel factor decomposition
and it's a generalization of singular
value decomposition blue blue background
means that we have seen this light
before and this was exactly what we need
to find hidden variables in stock prices
so remember the rows were stock prices
the columns were time stamps if we feed
in this array into the Python packets we
and ask for run to decomposition we'll
get the two vectors the projections over
stocks in a two dimensional space and we
get the two behaviors the two hidden
variables the global growth of the
economy and the Internet boom here at
2000 2001 an even better interpretation
of singular value decomposition is by a
matrix of who buys what so suppose we
have a store and we are selling we have
so many customers and we have so many
products
and suppose in this in this fictitious
store all these people buy all these
products and all these people all the
blue people buy all the blue products
and so on and so forth
and there's no intersection between the
people in degree in the green concept
green sedan variable and the people in
the blue sedan variable and the people
in the pink Hidden Valley right so let's
assume that the green blob corresponds
to people who are fashion fashion aware
and the products are fashionable shoes
the blue blob the blue hidden Barbie
correspond to Apple fans who will buy
any anything that any eye product iPad
iPhone I anything hi Mac and the third
corresponds to affluent people who buy
jewelry and so on so the singular value
decomposition in this case if we ask for
UNK three decomposition will give three
pairs of vectors the u1 v1 which will
correspond to the first concept
correspond means that this vector will
have zeros on everywhere except for the
people who like shoes who are fashion
aware and this vector will have zeros
everywhere except for the place that
correspond to fashion products shoes and
so on the same for the blue blog Apple
fans and Apple products affluent people
and jewelry products right so this is
what singular value decomposition does
if we have a tensor and if our tensor
has very nice blocks all these people
bought all these products during all
these time stamps right and all these
people bought all this product during
those time stamps and so on then the
perfect decomposition will give us of
rank three will give us Triplets of
vectors and this will be indicator
vectors more or less indicator vectors
for which person participates in the
first concept shoes which product
participates in the first concept and
which time stamps participate in the
first project so suppose that the
fashion of where people shop during the
week days the Apple fans're shop during
the summer months
and because that's when their big break
so big big discounts or whatever and
jewelry jewelry lovers buy stuff during
the holidays right so this is the
interpretation of the vector that
perfect generates now there is a big
advantage because if you want to do
forecasting we don't want to forecast
how many times Smith will call Johnson
or this person will buy shoes we can do
forecasting on the three major concepts
and the three hidden variables who have
discovered and then we can reverse
engineer the how the tensor will evolve
so we need only three models in this toy
example only three forecasting models we
can use it or regression we can use
delay coordinate embedding whatever we
want but we need only three models as
opposed to four million square which is
completely out of the question so we
repeat again the observation that when
we are able to find patterns we can do
forecasting and this is exactly what
para [ __ ] helps us do we can spot hidden
variables over customer products and
time or caller Collie and time as we'll
see next and so on so let's see
application of perfect on three settings
on a local school network on network
traffic who sends packets to whom and on
Facebook whose post messages to whose
wall so for the first dataset that was a
real data from a European country four
million customers calling each other
over two weeks so the first we did part
of our analysis the first triplet of
vector was not very interesting
everybody was calling everybody else and
there was a weekly periodicity not many
phone calls during the weekday weekends
okay not surprising the third or fourth
triplet of vectors was very interesting
this is the vector it has four million
entries hard to plot but all of them are
near zero except one the second vector
which corresponds to receivers again
four million entries all of them near
zero except for five and the third
Vektor had 15 time ticks sorry 14 time
ticks and it was nonzero and only four
days of activity everything else was
high it so this was very surprising
because we looked into the anonymize
date of course and this person or
institution or this originator of
uncle's would call each other of the
five receivers roughly 200 times a day
for those four days so we we were not
allowed to look into more detail because
of privacy issues of course so we gave a
name we call this pattern Godfather
we're calling this God children for some
reason it may very well be very good
reasons it may be the head of the head
of a corporation giving instructions to
the managers of the comparation
for a big a big show that the
corporation would like to do so could be
batteries it could be good reasons but
that point want to make is that the
power of fact the composition was able
to find this very interesting pattern
without doing anything fancy that's it
you load the matrix below the tensor we
press the button and you look at the
first few triplets and four and and this
pattern showed up with exactly the
details are in this paper the the second
dataset is network traffic from also a
public data set the main the main author
here is evangelist when Yale's public
psyches a le started this data set the
the tensor had no temporal mode in this
example it was only source destination
source IP destination IP address and
port number and one of the one of the
hidden variables had the following three
vectors there was only one destiny or
only one source only one destination but
they were communicating over multiple
ports which may be a port scanning
attack or a peer-to-peer network which
is hopping across multiple ports to
avoid detection in either way a
suspicious pattern
the third dataset was Facebook so now
the tensor the modes of the ten circles
the wall owner the third the second mode
was the person who posted on this wall
and the third mode was timestamp so one
of the this is one of the triplets one
of the hidden variables so among the
several thousands of customers
there was only one only one was the wall
owner the posters were several of them
but this activity this activity happened
on only one day which is strange because
other other activities they have one or
two wall owners a few posters one or two
posters and the activity spanned several
days so one possible explanation is that
this is the birthday of of the wall
owner and these posters posted on his
wall his or her wall to wish wish this
person happy birthday so the conclusion
is that the tensor analysis can find
hidden variables and can find patterns
when we have triplets or when we have
shorts destination and times them and as
we said the patterns can help us spot
anomalies if if reality deviates from
our expectation and as we said it
extends SVD and matrix factorization to
higher mode matrices higher mode tensors
so here is the excellent survey by
Tamara Caulder we have a new survey a
few years ago with Nicolas Sudhir
applause and colleagues and we are
almost at the end of the part one the
conclusions are again the problem of
forecasting is closely related to patent
discovery to lossy compression to
similarity searching in the past and to
anomaly and outlier detection all the
material we are covering is is in this
website so I'll wait I will give you two
seconds to figure out to download it or
to write or snap a photograph I feel
free to stop it if stop the video if
you're watching offline
and here is the one-page summary of this
presentation for similarity search
across time series euclidean distance is
the prevailing distance time warping is
good only if we have voice signals for
if we want to spot periodicities the
digital signal processing provides
valuable tools like the discrete Fourier
transform and even better the discrete
wavelet transform if we want to do
linear forecasting which is very
successful for linear systems the
autoregressive methodologies they must
try and it's the stepping stone for more
advanced methodologies like the Holt
winters and Kalman filters if we are
sure that there is no the system we are
studying has nonlinearities then we have
to resort to log plots and delayed
coordinate embedding method lock plots
and similarity search the nearest
neighbor search we had a detour on the
gray box modelling and a powerful
lotka-volterra equations which model
virus propagation market penetration
product competition prey-predator
relationships and and more and finally
we saw tensors that they can spot
patterns when we have time evolving
evolving times time time sequences the
bumper-sticker version of this whole
presentation is that if we have a time
series as that the station's statistics
book say we should plot it and as we saw
in this presentation it pays off to do
the Fourier transform and the wavelet
transform looking for strange patterns
and this the end of this presentation
thank you very much
and let's go back again so that and here
is the place where you can download all
this information